plus un seul téléphone ne sera vendu en
chine sans que son utilisateur associe
son visage à son numéro de téléphone
c'est obligatoire depuis le 1er décembre
une façon de sécuriser un peu plus le
cyberespace selon les autorités mais
aussi de resserrer un peu plus le
contrôle de la population
[Musique]
en 2016 la série black mirror imaginez
un monde où chaque citoyen serait notée
avec des conséquences directes dans la
vie quotidienne
cette réalité c'est déjà le quotidien de
millions de chinois dans une quarantaine
de villes l'état expérimente un système
de crédit social
extrait de l'émission envoyé spécial à
18 ans huang lu s'est vu attribuer une
note 1000 points qui évoluent en
fonction de ses actions elle jette un
papier par terre
c'est une incivilité qui lui coûte 50
points et 100 points si elle traverse au
feu rouge par s'est finalement l'accès à
un crédit ou à certains emplois qui peut
être interdit si l'état chinois peut
classer ses citoyens en différentes
catégories
c'est grâce à la reconnaissance faciale
qui se généralise et au croisement de
données
cette intelligence artificielle apporte
beaucoup pour la sécurité les villes le
gouvernement mais ça nous apporte aussi
une nouvelle expérience
les géants comme ali baba investissent
massivement dans le secteur
par exemple avec le paiement par
reconnaissance faciale
ça aide aussi à protéger la vie privée
quand vous entrez un mot de passe
quelqu'un peut le voir à côté de vous
alors que la reconnaissance faciale
c'est différent
[Musique]
dans la silicon valley aussi cette
technologie est tendance et une cote qui
donne accès à un crédit chez nous aussi
on ya recours
les en chine où l'on compte la moitié
des caméras du monde entier 200 millions
le fichage systématique soulève beaucoup
d'inquiétude ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal